Kiko wardana is an ambitious
architecture student who goes to the
best university in town her elder
brother duta is also a student he is
majoring in Theatrical Arts due to
dreams of becoming a producer someday
finally the third and youngest sibling
is Dodie he is a Schoolboy who usually
spends his day having fun with his
friends at first glance it may look as
though they belong to a wealthy family
but in reality it is the exact opposite
the wardanas are a lower middle class
family that live in a cramped house in
Jakarta Mr wardana works at a repair
shop while his wife Mrs wardana sells
cookies on a small scale although money
is always tight they have vowed to give
their children the best life they can
this is why the three siblings study in
upper class institutions however
everything is not as easy as it looks
antica's University she is always
bullied by the rich girls for her poor
dressing sense and lack of makeup as for
duta his dream of becoming a producer
remains a dream due to lack of funds he
has now given up and is on the verge of
changing careers finally the little boy
Dodie is often teased by his mates for
wearing cheap sneakers despite all this
the family tries to be happy with what
they have every night they gather around
and have dinner together where Mr
wardana cracks a few jokes and makes
everyone laugh the siblings also team up
and have fun from time to time in one
instance they sneak into a rich couple's
wedding and enjoy free food there Tikka
meets her Crush Bayou who does menial
jobs to earn a living after a while the
siblings are caught but they seem to be
used to it they simply run away not
caring about the consequences but one
day Everything Changes Mr wardana
suddenly passes away in his sleep
leaving the family devastated now the
major source of their income is gone and
since they have no savings living is
going to get extremely tough hence that
night Mrs wardana gathers her children
to make some important decisions let me
save you some time you should probably
stop selling cookies the Elder siblings
Tikka and duta know what's coming so
they express their desire to leave
University with immediate effect however
Mrs wardana says they don't have to she
respects her late husband's decisions
and that's why the children must
continue studying and graduate for the
funds Mrs wardana has decided to sell
the house the decision is a tough one
but it is something that has to be done
the next morning as the family is
preparing for the day two lawyers
suddenly show up outside with some
important news to explain in detail they
play a video on their laptop and
surprisingly Mr wardana is in it at
first he jokes about being alive but
soon comes to the point he explains that
he recorded this video a few months back
knowing that he might die soon now he
has an important announcement to make in
a shocking turn of events he reveals
that he is actually rich the family
cannot believe what they are hearing and
Mr wardana goes on to say that he is the
son of one of the richest families in
Indonesia in fact he has a large
inheritance which he kept hidden from
his family for 21 years the only reason
was that he wanted his wife and children
to be independent but now that he is
gone he wants them to have the money and
live a proper life at last before the
video ends Mr wardana says that he loves
his family a lot hearing all this Mrs
wardana and the children are left in
utter disbelief even after the lawyers
are gone they are still convinced that
everything is just a prank however when
they go to Mr Ward on his bank that day
they are handed over a massive amount of
500 million rupee the lawyer from
earlier also shows up and reveals that
once they spend this amount they can
withdraw more elated the family
immediately heads outside to enjoy their
Newfound wealth at first they enter a
fancy restaurant book the VIP room and
order all the lavish Delicacies they
even invite a poor man and force him to
eat with them following this they head
to the mall and go on a shopping spree
Mrs wordana gets loads of fancy clothes
for herself which she has always desired
on the other hand the children get
themselves new mobile phones and other
gadgets from this day onwards their
lives completely change so much for
being independent this family is as
materialistic as it gets the next day at
school the little boy Dodie makes his
friends jealous by flaunting his
expensive Adidas sneakers good thing he
didn't go for the Yeezys everyone is
stunned how a boy from a poor family
could afford these meanwhile Tika starts
dating her Crush by you one day his
motorcycle breaks down so Tikka buys him
a new one for a whopping 19 million
rupiah they ride it the entire day and
have fun but at night Bayou Returns the
motorcycle to her saying he can't just
take it at home Mrs wardana has become
obsessed with exotic clothes and jewelry
she buys a whole bunch of it and so in a
matter of just three days the 500
million rupiah evaporates however it is
not a problem at all as Mr wardana
mentioned in his video earlier more
funds will be available soon that day
the lawyers again arrive and play a
video once again Mr wardana greets his
family with a cheerful face and inquires
if they are living a lavish life he then
explains that they will get access to 15
billion rupia now which is 30 times the
previous amount this sends his family
into a state of frenzy starting the very
next day they go on a monstrous spending
spree at first they enter a large
mansion and immediately buy it without
any negotiations then they go to a
furniture store and buy whatever they
touch they also buy the security guard
there promising to pay him triple the
amount after this they go to a luxury
car showroom and buy not one but three
cars even though none of them know how
to drive as the days pass by the family
grows distant from one another even
though they have all the wealth in the
world the closeness and unity that they
used to have is slowly fading when Mr
wardana was alive they used to have
dinner together but now everyone eats
separately in particular the little boy
Dodie is very annoyed by what they have
become meanwhile tikka's Rich classmates
who used to bully her have suddenly
become her friends envious of her
Newfound wealth they pretend to have a
genuine interest in her life Tika also
doesn't mind being with them but in the
process she starts ignoring her real
friends who have always been by her side
they had dreamed of taking part in the
annual physics us competition and
winning it however now that tika has
become distant her friends have decided
to quit on the other hand the Elder
sibling duta's big day is approaching he
has organized a drama show for which he
has invested a lot of money every week
he keeps hiring famous actors and
actresses from all over the country not
realizing that they may be too expensive
due to Simply knows one thing his father
has left them with a lot of money as for
Mrs wardana the money has gotten inside
her head the most every evening while
she is returning home after picking
Dodie up from school she listens to some
Street musicians and tips them
handsomely well that's one good thing
they've done with the days passing by
more and more musicians arrive hoping to
get rewarded by her at one point the
number crosses 100 but Mrs wardona still
has enough money to tip all of them one
day someone catches her in the act and
clicks a video this video quickly goes
viral and it is even shown on the news
Mrs wardana is astounded that she is on
TV for the first time in her life so she
decides to continue the charade from the
neck day she wears extensive makeup and
goes to the same spot with a higher and
higher amount of cash she even gives
interviews and lies that she's been
helping Street musicians for years
amidst all of this the lawyers show up
for the umpteenth time and display
another video which Mr wardana had
recorded some months ago he cracks a few
cringe jokes cringe jokes what are those
and reveals that they will have access
to a further 15 billion rupiah the next
day with this the family except for
Dodie gets even more greedy Mrs wardana
has started showboating so much that one
day a reporter asks her if she would
like to donate to needy people since she
has set the bar very high Mrs wordana
says yes she sets a date and Promises to
provide a lot of food clothes and money
for the needy people meanwhile tika has
started spending an awful lot of time
with her rich friends she often goes on
trips with them parties with them and
even has sleepovers at their place in
the process Tika starts drinking heavily
and in one instance she almost gets
persuaded into swallowing a pill
fortunately with whatever ever since is
left inside of her she spits it out and
flushes it down the toilet Tika then
finally realizes that she is slowly
going into a downward spiral and the
getting out of it will be a challenge as
she proceeds to leave the bathroom she
also Hears A bunch of girls back biting
about her this makes her feel really bad
so she immediately heads to her true
friends and convinces them to practice
for the upcoming quiz competition on the
other hand duta has continued hiring new
Personnel even though they are not
really required sadly with only one day
left for his drama Premiere all of his
actors and actresses go on a strike they
want to get paid before the performance
unfortunately that evening the lawyers
arrive with some bad news they showcase
yet another one of Mr Ward on his videos
and while the family eagerly waits to
hear an amount he reveals that his
savings are finished the family is
shocked as they were expecting another
large sum Mrs wordana wants 200 million
rupiah for her charity show while Duda
is in debt of around 1 billion rupiah
despite the setback the family decides
to continue on with their lives Miss is
where Donna uses up all of her savings
to conduct the charity show Tika with
some motivation from her boyfriend gets
ready for her quiz competition and Duda
begs a powerful politician to fund his
drama in exchange for a small promotion
on the Grand Day everything seems to be
going as normal Mrs wardana has amassed
hundreds of boxes to deliver to the poor
Tika and her friends get on stage for
their quiz competition and Duda has
successfully managed his drama but soon
everything starts going downhill due to
the excessive crowd gathered outside Mrs
wardana's house a girl gets injured and
she has to be rushed to the hospital at
the quiz competition a group of
policemen suddenly arrive and apprehend
Tika and her rich friends on the
accusation of consuming narcotics
meanwhile at duda's drama show the
politician comes up on stage and tries
promoting himself however instead of
getting applauded he is insulted by the
crowd they call him a corrupt politician
who is good for nothing Duda tries to
calm them down but he fails as a result
the show which was supposed to run very
well is ruined in this way way the
entire family falters on the most
important day of their lives The only
positive is that Tikka is cleared after
her urine tests come out negative her
real friends and Bayou also forgive her
despite her rude attitude as of late
later at home the family gathers but
they are not in the mood to talk to one
another the situation is very tense and
to make matters worse the lawyers show
up with some bad news they have come
along with a man who reveals himself to
be Mr Ward on his younger brother the
lawyers then reveal that Mr wardana had
left some of his inheritance for his
brother and now the latter has come to
claim it since the family has already
spent a considerable chunk they will
have to hand over all of their current
properties like their house cars and so
on this breaks Mrs wardana and her
children but they also realize that
possessions are temporary the only thing
that lasts forever is family now they
finally come to the conclusion that
money and fame cannot guarantee
happiness in the next scene the family
is back at their old house living a
simple life like they used to Tika and
Bayou are getting married soon well due
to has finally come to terms with his
life however little did they know that
fate has yet another twist in their
lives one day the lawyers again show up
and display Mr wordana's video in this
video the old man is with his supposed
brother who has now taken all of their
property and to everyone's surprise he
reveals that the man is actually a paid
actor he also reveals that his savings
are not yet finished in fact they have
not even spent one percent of his wealth
Mr wardana simply lied about it so that
his family could again understand the
value of money he knew that they would
get too greedy and lose the togetherness
which had always been their strength at
last before the video ends Mr wardana
reminds his family that he loves them
very much even though he's been little
more than a Machiavellian prick in his
afterlife and that he will keep helping
them even though he has died at this
point Mrs fordana and her children are
brought to tears and it appears that
they have finally learned their lesson
however at the end of the movie Mrs
wordana cheekily puts on a golden
necklace indicating that she is ready to
go on yet another spending spree the
moral of the story is that money is not
the most important thing in life unless
you have a lot of it
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching